置
Tsugi no kanji desu keredo mo, mazu, kono
component; ue no component kore wa, kanji
no yon to onaji nan desu keredo mo, imagine
this type of net, soshite, shita no part,
kore nan desu keredo mo, kono kanji desu keredo
mo, kore dake de “straighten up,” “correct,”
“naosu,” to iu kanji desu.
So when you place a net, you have to straighten
up the net first.
To iu no de, kore de, “oku,” “together,”
desu ga, “oku,” “to place,” to ka
“to put” to iu imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, “koko ni hon wo oite kudasai.”
Particle kiwotsukete kudasai, “koko ni”
desu.
Sore kara, compound de, “nihon no ichi,”
kore wa “position” no imi desu.
式
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji ni wa story ga nain desu keredo
mo, kono hook kiwotsukete kudasai.
Koko ni, hook ga arimasu no de, kore wo kiwotsukete
kudasai.
Kono kanji nan desu keredo mo, kanji dake
de “ceremony” nan desu keredo mo.
Yoku, suffix.
Tatoeba, “kekkon shiki,” “marriage ceremony.”
“sotsugyō shiki,” “graduation ceremony.”
“osō shiki,” eh, kono, atarashii kotoba
desu keredo mo, “funeral” kono imi ga
arimasu.
石
Dewa tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa “stone”
desu.
Hitotsu kiwotsukete hoshii no ga kakutoki
desu ne. koko crossing wo onegaishimasu.
Kore wa dame desu.
Story wa nain desu keredo mo, kono kanji kun
reading.
kore wa “ishi” desu.
Tatoeba, nihonjin no typical na namae de “ishikawa-san.”
Sore kara, “ishi de dekita hashi,” “the
bridge made of stone.”
Sonna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sore kara, kun reading no hō nan desu keredo
mo, kore de “sekiyu,” “petrol,” aru
wa “oil” no imi desu.
Sore kara “hōseki,” “gemstone,” “jewelry,”
konna kanji wo tsukaimasu.
査
Dewa tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa “look
into” sore kara “investigate” to iu
imi ga arimasu.
Mō minna shitteiru ka to omoundesu keredo
mo ue no part.
Kore wa “tree” desu yo ne.
Sore kara shita no part nan desu keredo mo,
kore wa “me” to iu kanji to wa chigaimasu.
Kore “eye” desu keredo mo.
“Me” janakute, koko no ichiban shita no
line ga long line desu.
So you can imagine a story.
Someone with a big eye is looking into under
the tree for long time to investigate something.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading de
wa “sa” to iu yomikata wo shimasu.
Tatoeba, “chōsa” ari wa “chōsa suru,”
“to investigate.”
Sore kara, “kensa,” “kensa suru,”
“to inspect.”
Tatoeba, reibun toshite wa, “korona no geiin
wo chōsa shiteimasu” “I am investigating
the cause of COVID-19.”
熱
Tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa “heat,” “hot,”
“fever.”
Kono imi ga arundesu keredo mo.
Mazu, kono shita no part desu yo ne. kono
component.
Kono component wo mitara, “fire” no imi
wo omotte kudasai.
Sore kara, kono kanji.
Kono kanji wa “tsuchi,” ma, “soil.”
“Doyōbi” no “do” nan desu keredo
mo, “soil” to iu imi ga arimasu.
So you have lots of soil.
Sore kara, kono part, kono component wa “round,”
“marui” to iu imi ga arimasu.
So something round made out of soil, ma, you
can imagine pottery, and pottery needs to
be heated by fire.
So together, kore de, “heat,” ari wa “hot,”
“fever,” konna imi ga arimasu.
De, onyomi, on reading desu keredo mo, kore
“netsu.”
“netsu ga aru,” “I have a fever.”
“kōnetsu,” “high fever” to iu tsukaikata.
Sore kara kiwotsukete kudasai.
Kono kanji ga nani ka modifier wo suru toki,
tatoeba, “nettō,” “boiled/heated water”
to iu imi nan desu keredo mo, kono yomikata
ga “nettō” ni narimasu.
Sore kara, “nesshin,” “heated heart.”
“nesshin,” ma, “diligent,” to iu imi
desu keredo mo, kō iu yomikata ni mo kiwotsukete
kudasai.
Sore kara, kun reading no toki ni wa, “atsui.”
Tatoeba, “atsui kōhī,” “hot,” kore
wa temperature ga hot to iu imi de, “atsui
kōhī,” “hot coffee.”
Mō hitsotsu kiwotsukete kudasai.
“weather” no hot no toki ni wa kono kanji
wo tsukaimasu.
Kono kanji wa, nani ka, nomimono, drinks,
hot drinks dake ni tsukaimasu.
Sore wo kiwotsukete kudasai.
民
De wa, tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu kedo, “people” to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Kono component, kono kanji nan desu keredo
mo, kore wa “clan” sore kara “tribe”
“family” to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kore wa “boundary” desu yo ne.
So the clan under a certain boundary, sore
de, “people” to iu imi ni narimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading.
Kore wa “min” to iimasu.
Tatoeba, “kokumin, shimin, kenmin.”
Dakara kore wa kuni no hitobito.
Sore kara, “shimin.”
Kore wa “city,” shi no hitobito.
Sore kara, “kenmin.”
Kore wa prefecture no hitobito to iu imi desu.
Ato, “jyūmin,” kore wa sundeiru hitobito,
ma, “Resident.”
Ato, “nōmin,” kore wa “nō” tte iu
no wa “farmer” no imi desu. “nōmin”
to iu tsukaikata wo shimasu.
急
De wa, tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa “urgent,”
sore kara “hurry” to iu imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Kono component, imagine someone’s mouth
opening.
Sore kara, hand shape.
Sore kara, kono kanji wa “heart,” “kokoro,”
desu yo ne. “heart.”
So someone with a mouth opened, and sore kara,
hand sticking out, with heart.
This person must be in a hurry, to iu no de,
zenbu no component de “hurry” to iu imi
ga arimasu.
De, kunyomi nan desu keredo mo, kore “isoide
kudasai,” “hurry up,” to iu imi desu.
Sore kara, on reading.
Kore wa “kyū” to iimasu.
“Kyū na,” “urgent,” “yōji,”
“urgent matter.”
Sore kara, kore “kyūkō,” densha no express
train desu yo ne.
Sore kara “kyūkō ressha” to ka iimasu.
Ato “tokkyū,” “special express.”
Sore kara “kyūyō,” kore wa kyū na yōji
to kyūyō onaji desu keredo mo, kyūyō,
“urgent,” mata konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
紀
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa “era” no
imi ga arimasu.
De, chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Kono component, kono radical, desu keredo
mo, kore “ito hen” to iimasu.
Imi wa “thread” no imi desu.
Sore kara, kono migigawa no kono part, kore
wa kono kanji dake de “self” no imi ga
arimasu.
So when an individual or self and a thread
of special events get together, it’s kind
of a century or era to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata, desu keredo mo, onyomi de “ki.”
Tatoeba, “nijyūissēki,” “21st century.”
Sore kara, “nijyūissēki no shakai,”
“society in the 21st century.”
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
倍
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, mazu compoenent
nan desu keredo mo, “person,” sore kara,
“stand,” “tatsu,” desu yo ne.
Sore kara “mouth,” “kuchi.”
So a person is standing with a big mouth to
advocate for himself so he can get twice.
Kono kanji no imi wa “twice” no imi ga
arimasu.
De, yoku sono “number,” sore kara, “bai,”
to issho ni, desu ne.
“twice,” “ni bai.”
Sore kara, “san bai,” “three times.”
Sore kara, “hyaku bai,” “hundred times.”
Konna counter no yaku ari mo arimasu.
Tatoeba, “nihongo no shukudai ga ni bai
ni natta,” “the homework became twice
as much.”
Kō itta tsukaikata wo shimasu.
参
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa “to participate.”
Sore kara desu ne, toki doki “to visit a
holy place” to iu imi mo detekimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Story wa naindesu keredo mo, ichiban ue no
bubun, kore wa katakana no “mu” to onaji
kakikata.
Sore kara, koko no bubun, kore wa “ōki”
desu yo ne.
Sore kara, koko no naka no part desu keredo
mo, kore wa kanji no “san” jya arimasen.
Chotto kono angle ga, kono angle wo motte
kudasai.
De, zenbu de “to participate” to iu imi
desu keredo mo.
Yomikata.
On reading wa “san” to iimasu.
“sanka, sanka suru.”
Tatoeba, “sono gēmu ni sanka shita,”
“I participated in that game.”
Sore kara, “sanpai suru,” “to worship.”
Kore ga “holy place” to iu imi ga arundesu
keredo mo, “sanpai suru,” kore, “to
worship” no imi ga arimasu.
Ato, minna ga yoku shitteiru, kun reading
de wa “mairu.”
Kore wa humble form of “to go” desu yo
ne. “mairimasu” to iu tsukaikata desu.
加
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa “to add,”
“to append,” ari wa “join,” no imi
ga arimasu.
De, chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Mazu, kono hidarigawa no kanji desu keredo
mo, kore “chikara,” by itself “power”
no imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara, migigawa.
Kore wa “mouth.”
“kuchi,” desu yo ne.
So you need to add something into your mouth
in order to get some power to iu no de, together,
kore de, “to add” to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata desu kedo.
On reading wa “ka” desu.
“sanka,” “to participate.”
Sore kara, “zōka,” “to increase.”
Sore kara, “kakō,” “to manufacture”
to ka, “process.”
Tatoeba, “kakō sareta tabemono,” “processed
food,” to iu, sō itta iikata wo shimasu.
Ato, kun reading desu keredo mo.
“kuwaeru,” “to add.”
Taoteba, “nabe ni mizu wo kuwaetekudasai,”
“add water into the pan.”
Sonna imi ga arimasu.
個
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi to wa desu ne, “individual”
to iu to, sore kara counter, general counter
toshite mo tsukawaremasu.
Component wo chotto mite mimasu.
Kono mazu, hidari no component, kore wa person
no radical desu yo ne.
sore kara migigawa desu keredo mo, kore “furui,”
“old,” desu keredo mo.
Sore kara nani ka “box.”
So imagine you can see an old person who is
inside the box so that he or she became a
matured individual to iu no de, futatsu awasete,
kore de “individual” to iu imi desu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo.
On reading wa, tatoeba, “kojin,” “individual
person.”
Sore kara “koshitsu,” kore “individual
room.”
Sore kara “kosē,” kore “personality
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara kono counter desu keredo mo, number
plus counter “ko” to iu no de,
Tatoeba, “ikko,” “one.”
Tatoeba, “ringo wo ikko kudasai,” “give
me one apple.”
Kore de tatoeba, “niko,” “two.”
“sanko,” “three.”
“Ringo wo sanko kudasai,” “give me three
apples.”
Sō iu tsukaikata wo shimasu.
De, “how many” to iu toki ni wa, “nanko”
desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa “to oppose”
to ka, “disagree,” “anti-something”
so iu imi ga arimasu.
De, story desu keredo mo, you can imagine
a story like this part, like imagine a big
barricade and a person is holding this big
barricade in order to oppose something or
in order to disagree something.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, onyomi, kore ga “han.”
Tatoeba, “hantai suru,” “to disagree,
to oppose.”
Koko particle wo kiwotsukete kudasai.
Particle wa “ni” desu.
“Sono iken ni hantai suru,” “I oppose
against this opinion.”
Sore kara, “anti-“ to iu imi ni mo narimasu.
Tatoeba, “Hansen,” kore wa “sensō ni
hantai suru” to iu imi. “anti-war.”
Sore kara, “hannichi,” kore wa “nihon
ni hantai suru” “anti-Japan” to iu imi desu.
賛 Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa “to praise,”
to ka “to agree, agreement” to iu imi
ga arundesu kedo.
Mazu, component.
Kono ue no koko, desu yo ne, kore wa “otto,”
“husband,” to ka “man” no imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara tsugi no kono shita no bubun desu
keredo mo, kono kanji dake de “kai,” “shell,”
to ka “wealth” to iu imi mo arimasu.
We used to use shell as like, coin.
To iu no de, wealth to ka money to ka sō
itta imi ni nattekimasu.
So, two men agreed on the price or the wealth
of something, to iu no de, kore “agree”
no imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata desu ga, on reading ga “san.”
Tatoeba, “sansei suru.”
Hantai wa “hantai suru,” “to oppose”
desu yo ne.
Particle wo kiwotsukete kudasai.
“kare no iken ni sansei suru” particle
“ni” wo tsukaimasu.
果
Tsugi no kanji.
Kono kanji desu kedo mo.
Mazu, ue no component, kono component.
kore wa daijobu desu ne.
Tanaka-san no “ta” to iu no de, “field”
to iu imi desu.
Sore kara, shita wa “tree,” “ki” desu.
De, together, so the field of trees to produce
fruits.
So kono kanji, zenbu de “fruit” no imi
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, “kudamono,” “fruits” desu
kedo,
“kenkō no tame ni, mainichi takusan kudamono
wo tabete kudasai.”
Sore kara, “sēka,” kore “achievement,
accomplishment.”
Ato “kekka,” “result,” konna kotoba
mo arimasu.